[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur tv5 monde
et vos chaînes locales et régionales
voici les titres de l'actualité le
moment était plus qu'attendue le
déconfinement a débuté ce mercredi dans
toute la france une bonne nouvelle
notamment pour les restaurateurs et
toute une filière
reportage auprès d'eux à fuir de via
occitanie dans un instant la culture
sera aussi de l'ornière musées théâtres
et salles de cinéma retrouvent leurs
habitués à saint-etienne la première
projection avait lieu des 6 heures nous
racontera la rédaction de tl7 la
télévision de la loire se préparer au
pire à un mois de la saison des cyclones
aux antilles la chaîne via atv a pu
suivre un exercice de formation mené par
l'armée française
une opération préparatoire
impressionnante comme vous le voyez sur
ces images
et puis elle n'a même pas 30 ans et elle
est déjà chef d'un des meilleurs
restaurants de monaco le coc ya en fin
de journal vous découvrirez grâce à
monaco info
la cuisine de victoria vaille emilia
porte parole d'un savoir-faire
sud-américain à monte carlo
c'est donc devenu possible manger en
terrasse
allez au musée ou au cinéma ces choses
simples qui nous avait tant manqué fermé
depuis la fin octobre et le début du
deuxième confinement l'ensemble des
professionnels avaient hâte bien sûr de
retrouver leurs clients les règles liées
aux protocoles sanitaires n'ont pas
empêché les sourires de s'afficher sur
les visages notamment en terrasse quand
il faisait beau retour sur ces premiers
instants de déconfinement dans le
sud-ouest à toulouse avec stéphane
bourgeois pour vioxx italie
je vous emm il est bon d'aller dans les
pochettes et vous pouvez partir c'est ok
cela fait onze ans que martin fait rage
des grossistes au marché d'intérêt
national de toulouse
aujourd'hui c'est le rush les terrasses
des restaurants ouvrent une reprise à
100 % de l'activité qui fait du bien
puisqu'elle a connu une baisse de 50% de
son chiffre d'affaires pendant les
confinements c'était vraiment une scène
de guerre ou quoi dans notre entrepôt
parce qu'en fait il fallait reprendre
vraiment les habitudes reprendre tous
les arrivages donc en grosse quantité
ce qu'on travaillait on va dire que sur
50 % d'activité donc le disent a
vraiment été une journée de reprise où
on avait perdu
vraiment tous nos automatismes les
muscles rouillé en trois jours son
entreprise a livré plus d'une tonne de
marchandises aux différents
restaurateurs de toulouse c'est le cas
pour yoann fail qui rouvre dès ce midi
s'annonce et s'arrêtent pas les messages
ou pour nous comme en terrasse l'équipe
s'active
malgré certaines restrictions sanitaires
à respecter ces six portes au maximum on
garde toujours les maîtres de dix ans on
a mis des panneaux en plus pour protéger
et sur la terrasse voix de mètres carrés
par personne
50 personnes le restaurant affiche
complet malgré une météo mitigée
les premiers clients sont enfin là on
avait promis rassurent ils semblent
ravis de retrouver leurs habitudes ou
que tu es content de retrouver l'équipe
et y avait aussi un côté solidarité quoi
on avait presque envie de devenir
presque pour le côté allez on vous aide
à relancer la machine ça a été une
galère pour manger sur les chantiers
toujours des mcdo d ela revenir à la vie
réelle pouvoir faire un restaurant mais
ma chérie c'est le bonheur ça fait du
bien mais ça va faire du bien mon petit
estomac qui va enfin pouvoir grossir ce
que j'ai perdu trop de poids depuis les
restaurants sont fermés prochaines dates
clés le 30 juin pour une réouverture
totale des établissements eux aussi
trépigner d'impatience les amoureux du
cinéma ont enfin pu retrouver le chemin
des salles obscures après plus de six
mois de fermeture à saint-etienne le
cinéma le méliès propose d'ailleurs une
première séance des 6 heures du matin
avec petit déjeuner à la clé la
rédaction de tl7 la télévion de la loire
étaient sur place regarder
heures du matin une foule de cinéphiles
et du frisson c'est comme ça qu'on peut
résumer la réouverture du cinéma c'est
parce que vous avez complètement raison
et qui agace en détiennent qu'on peut
être au cinéma une heure pareille et le
méliès et une équipe merveilleuse qui
fait un travail de dingue et et je
dirait vraiment que c'est le maire
cinéma de france a placé matin public
tombé du lit mais heureux et un
directeur de salle bouleversé il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion enfin moi je
vais rentrer en vrac et ça récompense
tout le travail d'une équipe depuis des
mois et là il ya des spectateurs il ya
des jeunes des familles très forte
émotion
j'ai du mal à cacher la naf il grossit
devant l'entrée du méliès hissé à
saint-etienne avec ce même besoin
essentiel de cinéma on commence déjà par
les cinémas et après on va bosser comme
un peu d'habitude j'ai plutôt cinéma à
22h alors ça pique un peu quand même
mais je sais bien que ça arrive qu'on
puisse enfin y accéder à nouveau
enfin les portes s'ouvrent première
séance de 6h30 et les réflexes du
confort devant le grand écran d'un on y
contente d'être avec la copine tu tu
ressembles des applaudissements qui met
les larmes avant les premières images de
petites mamans de cécile sciamma
profondément émouvante
il ya eu des spectateurs de tout âge des
parents et des mamies qui disait je vais
voir le premier film parce que j'ai des
enfants qui dorment encore à la maison
des plates des jeunes qui lie siens qui
sont mieux
soit seul soit plusieurs et qui vont en
cours à 8 heures après le public sort
d'une seule pour entrer dans une autre
une journée folle avec 22 séances de
réouverture du musée sainte etienne et
le public qui répond présent
c'est là aussi l'essentiel le
déconfinement bien sûr et toujours mais
aussi un ouf de soulagement pour les
exposants et les musées à bordeaux pour
célébrer le retour des visiteurs les
bassins de lumière propose une
invitation au voyage en méditerranée
un parcours de l'impressionnisme à la
modernité qui révèle le lien entre la
création artistique et les rives
méditerranéennes immersion dans les
chefs-d'oeuvre de renoir de monnaie de
chagall avec bénédicte 2 1 de la
rédaction de télé 7 chaînes du groupe
sud ouest jusqu'en janvier 2022 money
chagall et renoir investissent
l'ancienne base sous marine de bordeaux
une exposition numérique hors norme
spécialement repensé pour imprégner les
lieux c'est une expression qui avait été
créé initialement pour les baux de
provence en 2013 dans les carrières de
lumière j'avais aussi par culturespaces
puis à l'atelier des lumières et donc du
coup cette année on a pris huit mois
pour refaire intégralement toute cette
exposition changer quelques musiques qui
nous semblait moins opportune et surtour
travaillé graphiquement une à une toutes
les images et toutes les coupes et
géographie donc cela donne au final
quelque chose d'assez différent
fermé depuis six mois les bassins de
lumière s'apprête à rouvrir avec un
protocole sanitaire strict avec une
jauge limitée à 450 visiteurs en même
temps cette réouverture est un défi
financier
bien sûr il ya une pression de passer
cinq mois sans exploitation donc sans
billetterie etc
c'est compliqué pour les sites comme les
nôtres maintenant on espère bénéficier
du même succès que l'année dernière et
la cie ont connu une belle année comme
ça s'arrêtera pas du tout en cause le
projet mais il faut que bien sûr ça
marche je pense que ce qu'on propose est
à la hauteur des attentes du public
rendez vous est fixé le 19 mai les
visiteurs pourront découvrir une double
programmation en journée et en soirée
des visiteurs qui auront l'occasion de
se perdre dans les treize mille mètres
carrés d'exposition jusqu'au 2 janvier
2022 et à marseille la culture fait
également le retour du public le musée
des civilisations de l'europe et de la
méditerranée aussi appelé
mucem expose une partie des oeuvres du
célèbre jeff koons
les visiteurs peuvent ainsi voir ou
revoir le chien ballon aux côtés des
pièces permanente du musée
au total ce sont vingt oeuvres de jeff
koons qui resteront dans le musée
phocéen
jusqu'au 18 octobre prochain vous voyez
là quelques images de nos confrères et
amis de la provence sur place sans
transition une belle initiative à
présent celle du maire d'un village de
l'ariège qui en plus de sa casquette
d'élu a aussi récupéré celle d'éboueurs
pour faciliter la vie de ses habitants
et tenter de faire des économies et bien
le maire ramasse donc les ordures
ménagères de ses administrés écoutez ses
explications au micro de stéphanie
leborne journaliste à la dépêche du midi
sur place
j'avais 19 ans que je suis à la mairie
wendel a maintenant et au fur et à
mesure et j'ai remplacé un employé
communal comme un conte n'a plus
qu'après ils vont apprécier l'employé
qui le fait à moi je file un coup de
main
vous pensez que pour l'avenir je pourrai
discuter un peu avec le smectom parce
que bon on leur facilite quand même à la
voyez c'est propre c'est des câbles il y
arrive il ya qu un seul point de
collecte est un ami que nous nous
faisons de fonds par semaine eux aussi
ont vu leurs missions évoluer les
facteurs ne livre plus seulement le
courrier mais aussi le pain dans les
milieux ruraux
une façon de faire face à la baisse de
l'activité postale est de créer du lien
dans les villages regardez ce reportage
de la chaîne wéo la chaîne de la voix du
nord à bouchain cours aujourd'hui
yannick lespinasse le facteur ne livre
pas que le courrier bonjour madame
berthod seul facteur
marie-rose 92 ans a droit à sa livraison
quotidienne de pain il m'a amené du pain
et sa gentillesse surtout vous savez
quand on est seul et puis on aime bien
surtout écoles confinement on a
quelqu'un avec qui parler
baguette ancien de tradition pain
complet depuis maintenant trois ans
yannick livre le pain dans six communes
à proximité d'albert dans la somme une
offre proposée par la poste pour
diversifier l'activité de facteurs c'est
parce que
non une baisse sensible du courrier donc
ces nouveaux services vont nous
permettre de d'avancer quoi un service
de proximité dont l'objectif est
également de renforcer le lien social
souvent fragile dans les petites
communes
c'est dans cette boulangerie que sont
confectionnés les 50 baguette livrés
chaque jour par les facteurs de la poste
dans le secteur d'albert pour stéphanie
ce service de livraison est un moyen de
faire des économies tout en restant au
chevet d'une clientèle sédentaires ils
aiment bien se confier quand il y avait
le pôle portage à domicile
il aimait bien se confier avec la
boulangère tout seul nos boys confie
accueil facteurs il aime bien des
petites visites
si le service est gratuit pour les
clients il est en revanche facturés aux
entreprises qui font livrer leurs
produits car la poste ne livre pas que
le pain mais également repas ou
médicaments
allez bonne journée l'économie dans nos
régions à présent avec vous michel
picaud bonjour vous allez nous faire
découvrir une histoire aujourd'hui d'une
pme originale cette entreprise élèves
des insectes pour nourrir les poissons
qui se retrouveront dans nos assiettes
elle est basée dans la somme michel
picaud vous nous en parler
bonjour cyril bonjour à vous tous
question pour commencer que mangent les
truites la réponse elles sont carnivores
allemange donc des verts des insectes et
parfois même d'autres poissons dans les
élevages de truites
elle mange souvent des farines de
poissons issus en majorité des sardines
et autres anchois pêchés au large de
l'amérique du sud puis importés dans nos
fermes piscicoles
une situation pas très écologique est
plutôt onéreuse d'où l'idée d'innover
hafid d'élever des insectes pour les
transformer en farine pour nourrir les
truites l'entreprise cultive ainsi dans
ces fermes des mouches soldats noirs et
les transforment en protéine alternative
aux farines pour nourrir donc ces
truites
mais ces insectes sont aussi transformée
en huile pour l'alimentation des porcs
et des volailles
l'entreprise a terminé sa toute nouvelle
le ferme verticale dans la somme qui
permettra de produire 100 mille tonnes
d'aliments chaque année et 15 mille
tonnes de protéines destinées aux
farines pour réaliser ce projet et
ouvrir une nouvelle ferme d'élevage
prochainement aux états unis et bien
cette fois ci l'entreprise a levé en
2020 140 millions d'euros
il faut dire que ce marché est en plein
essor et pour nous consommateurs me
direz vous que faut-il en penser
et bien innover fidh a eu la brillante
idée de lancer en 2019 une nouvelle
filière de truites nourris à l'insecte
allan a même fait une marque ou plus
tant la belle truite nourris à l'insecte
une cinquantaine de grandes surfaces
dans le nord de la france c'est en ile
de france ont donc vendu 6 truites
nourris à la secte ce fut une première
mondiale
désormais une huile d'insectes est entré
dans la composition d'aliments pour les
volailles elle remplace le soja de plus
en plus décrié pour son impact
environnemental
vous pouvez donc trouver et vous
trouverez prochainement dans les rayons
des hypermarchés la première volaille
française nourrir l'insecte on n'arrête
pas le progrès merci michel py coup on
vous retrouve dans une prochaine édition
du grand jt des territoires pour nous
parler économie de nos régions bien sûr
on continue dans les régions avec cette
proche de marseille et de bordeaux à la
une des éditions spéciales du point
cette semaine le magazine hebdomadaire
ou fera notamment découvrir la
révolution agricole actuellement en
cours à bordeaux
il sera aussi question du bilan de
pierre hurmic le maire écologiste de la
ville de bordeaux dix mois après son
élection at il réussi son pari les
critiques sont pour le moins nombreuses
notamment de la part de ses opposants et
puis dans l'édition consacrée à
marseille
zoom sur la reconstruction de la
deuxième ville de france et plus
précisément sur les nombreuses
initiatives qui fleurissent dans les
quartiers nord de la ville pour profiter
du retour en terrasse et du soleil de
marseille la rédaction du point vous
proposera aussi quelques bons plans pour
les terrasses a réservé notamment à des
milliers de kilomètres de là en
guadeloupe
al'approche de la saison cyclonique les
forces armées se préparent à intervenir
en cas de catastrophe dans les caraïbes
pendant une semaine 400 soldats de
martinique de guadeloupe de guyane et de
la république dominicaine ont participé
à un exercice d'envergure sur l'île de
marie galante
l'objectif c'est rodez la coopération
interarmées et surtout internationale
marlène mecque pour vyas atv martinique
sur place nous sommes le vendredi 7 mai
l'ouragan bob s'abat sur marie galante
une île dévastée des embarcations
perdition et une fuite d'hydrocarbures
sur un navire au large c'est en quelques
mots le scénario de l'exercice militaire
caraïbes 2021
les hommes et femmes du 33e régiment
d'infanterie de marine sont prêts à
intervenir une fois l'ouragan passé il
faut faire vite et c'est ici au poste de
commandement que tout est coordonné en
liaison directe avec le centre
opérationnel installé à fort de france
ont procédé à des reconnaissances sur
toute la surface de l'île avec un
système de découpage géographique qui
nous permet de rien laisser derrière
nous et d'avancer pas à pas pour
réouvrir la circulation jusqu'aux
parties les plus reculés de l'île et
permettre d'acheminer soit du
ravitaillement hooglede dans l'île ceux
de permettre d'évacuer les sinistrés qui
andreu la nécessité dans cette barge 5
blessés près à être transporté vers le
bâtiment dumont d'urville stationnées
aux larges l'évacuation des populations
s'effectue avec un détachement militaire
de république dominicaine assurer une
action coordonnée fluide en situation de
catastrophe naturelle c'est tout l'enjeu
de cet exercice le timing de cet
exercice qui se situe deux mois avant
l'ouverture doit un mois avant
l'ouverture
je dirais officiel de la saison
cyclonique mais trois mois avant le pic
nous permet justement de nous rôder et
d'être d'être prêts à intervenir très
rapidement
le jour où malheureusement une telle
catastrophe arriverait et c'est
justement cette capacité à coordonner
différents corps d'armée et une taie
civile sur ce type d'opération que le
commandement sud de l' us air force est
venu observer cette année une expérience
semble-t-il concluante l'armée
américaine envisage de participer au
prochain exercice en 2022
on reste aux antilles sur ces images
encore impressionnante de la chaîne atv
l'eau d'une mangrove est devenu rose
bonbon
le phénomène qui s'est déjà produit l'an
dernier est lié à la concentration d'une
micro algues la dune elias a li na c'est
son nom c'est un phénomène naturel donc
causé aussi par la salinité de l'eau qui
devrait disparaître lors des prochaines
pluies
c'est cette même algues qui colore en
rose les salins de camargue toujours sur
l'eau maison bretagne zoom sur le
kaskelot le cachalot en danois
c'est un navire habitués de la rade de
brest après les fêtes nautiques de 2008
et de 2016
il revient dans la cité du ponant sous
pavillon français avec une nouvelle
mission offrir aux étudiants une
expérience inoubliable
amarré au port du château le trois-mâts
entend bien accueillir à terme 9000
scolaires pour leur donner une autre
image de la mer un reportage de
christophe bouchet pour tébéo la chaîne
du couple télégramme sur place 47 mètres
de long de 1200 mètres carrés de voilure
et une capacité d'embarquement à la
journée 200 personnes le français sur
l'eau est tout bonnement majestueux cet
ancien voilier danois vit une seconde
jeunesse
la vocation de ce trois mâts qui bat
pavillon tricolore depuis de 8,18
devenir un navire école
oui des jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans des
jeunes qui viendront et noah à mettre à
faire du cac à faire là-bas à faire
enfin tous les tâches multiples et
variées qui aura sur qui peut y avoir
sur un grand voilier comme le français
si l'école de la vie celle des gens de
mer que souhaite inculquer patrice zurro
jeunes stagiaires une expérience unique
qui forge un caractère
le but n'est pas d'en faire des mains le
but est d'apprendre aux jeunes qui vont
le savoir est servie ensemble le respect
des uns le respect des autres et la mer
et me r est la meilleure éducatrice
possible parce que si vous respectez pas
les fondamentaux du savoir être savoir
vivre ensemble est ma
on vous remet à niveau rapidement un
séjour sur un trois mâts n'est pas une
expérience en vase clos mais bel et bien
une ouverture vers l'autre et sur le
monde qui nous entoure
il faut avoir une vision globale de la
problématique actuelle et la vie
ensemble mais aussi la vie avec la avec
l'environnement et la planète est telle
qu'un voilier pour un tel qu'un voilier
pour pour parler tout ça si aujourd'hui
seules 16 personnes peuvent dormir à
bord à terme une quarantaine pourront
profiter d'un tel coucher de soleil et
d'une nuit en mer sous les étoiles
le 5 mai dernier emmanuel macron le
président de la république commémorer le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
bonaparte et encore c'est évidemment
cette célébration s'étalera sur
plusieurs mois avec des expositions
notamment ajaccio là où l'empereur est
née une messe commémorative s'est
déroulée à la chapelle impériale
écoutez à ce sujet le maire de la ville
laurent marc angeli au micro de la
rédaction de via télévisé sur place
c'est dans la rue fesch vous avez le
cours napoléon au dessus avec avec le
nom des rues des places les statuts
l'urbanisme vous avez déjà en soi un
héritage qui est encore bien visible
ce musée qui est à plein de trésors et
la bibliothèque et qu'il jouxte
également c'est l'héritage déjà je
dirais matériel prêt vous avez un
héritage historique la ville d'ajaccio
et très redevable à cette famille à cet
homme en particulier
on les pensait disparu mais comme les
vinyles ils signent leur retour en force
les dvd au sortent des cartons
maintenant à fougères en bretagne un
magasin consacré uniquement aux dvd a
ouvert en avril et philippe bertout pour
la chaîne de tv air à rennes s'est rendu
sur place pour regarder ses trésors
une nouvelle boutique vient tout juste
d'ouvrir ses portes fougères la
quincaillerie du cinéma c'est son don
est entièrement consacré à la vente d'un
produit unique
le dvd le support physique des films de
cinéma récemment mise à mal par les
plateformes de streaming nos dix mille à
peu près des murs fumeurs on va dire
d'auteur et du cinéma du monde français
s'est à peu près tous les films qu'on
voit plus au cinéma
on voit les classiques on voit pas les
films qu'ils sont
absent des médias jusque là philippe
roger vendait ses dvd lors de foires
salons ou marchés spécialisés
mais là que gide est passée par là une
boutique est devenu nécessaire avec la
même logique qu'une librairie le client
vient chercher le septième heure mais
surtout un conseil ou une suggestion
pour sortir des sentiers battus enfin
pleurez personne qui va chercher un
dessin animé après tu dis tiens vous
avez ça et puis les gens ils regardent
fur et à mesure il détient mais lui il a
fait ça comme il l'a fait star ne savais
pas et puis on lui on discute et puis à
part avec un film du nanar au
chef-d'oeuvre
il y a donc beaucoup de pepita retrouver
dans les rayonnages de la quincaillerie
du cinéma en témoignent les nombreuses
palme d'or du festival de cannes mais
aussi ce quasi introuvables dersou
ouzala de 1975 signé akira kurosawa
les connaisseurs apprécieront c'est une
épouvantable habitudes estivales les
abandons d'animaux se multiplient quand
sonne l'heure des vacances pour les
familles
pour s'y préparer et sensibiliser le
public
la spa vient de lancer son mois de
l'adoption une opération qui doit
permettre de trouver des familles
responsables pour les chiens les chats
et les nouveaux animaux de compagnie à
orgeval dans les yvelines comme dans les
62 refuse de l'association les équipes à
que donc toutes les personnes
intéressées
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
de tv 78 accompagné 36 jeunes brebis en
transhumance voilà une bien belle idée
de sortie dominicale originale à monture
e sur saône dans l'ouest des vosges une
association organisée pour la deuxième
fois la trance ou rhj réuni 180
personnes venues mené le troupeau d'une
éleveuse locales jusqu'aux prairie où
elles vont paître pendant six mois une
sortie formatrice et pour le moins
sportive racontée par louise hammond a
étiré la sont la rédaction de viège
elle déborde d'énergie prête pour le
grand départ
à monture e sur scène pas très loin de
dernier ces jeunes brebis vont entamer
leur transhumance et dans la vallée de
lourches une transe bourges donc
organisé par l'association droite va
lourches patrimoine après une première
édition en 2010 9 celle de l'année
dernière avait été annulé en raison de
la crise sanitaire
cette année plus de 80 personnes ont
répondu à l'appel pour venir encadrer le
troupeau dans le respect de quelques
règles avec des moutons il ya quelques
consignes par exemple pas de chien il ya
des gens qui ont l'habitude de se
promener avec leur chien et non
aujourd'hui il faut le laisser à la
maison
et puis on va faire en sorte que les
moutons ne rentre pas dans les jardins
voilà n'abîme pas quelques massifs de
fleurs juste en bordure de route et des
choses comme ça et c'est donc parti pour
brumbies et marcheurs si malgré quelques
kilomètres dans les pattes les ovins
sont toujours aussi dissipé il est temps
pour tout le monde de faire une pause
tous sont venus profiter du grand air
dans l'effort certes mais surtout la
convivialité
j'en pense que du bien c'est super
organisée en plus et puis les gens sont
sympathiques
le seul regret qu'on pourrait avoir
cette pour pouvoir faire un repas
convivial heures mais on va le faire un
pique nique chacun dans notre pas donc
on a pris ce qu'il fallait dire nos sacs
à dos le troupeau lui se rendra jusqu'au
prairie à une dizaine de kilomètres de
voitures sur sun pour l'éleveuse ces
transhumances c'est l'occasion de
partager son expérience et de faire
connaître son métier
ça permet de mélanger des milieux des
passions et de faire de nouvelles
rencontres devaient le rencontrer puis
de donner une autre image et les roches
aussi parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
important il reste encore quelques
kilomètres avant d'arriver à destination
les brebis passeront ensuite une longue
saison dans les prairies de clodo où
elles pourront peut-être jusqu'en
novembre prochain
on referme ce grand jt des terres et toi
en cuisine avec la découverte de la
nouvelle chef du coa de monte carlo
victoria vayer niya n'a que 27 ans et
elle a un parcours pour le moins très
atypique
cette jeune chef vénézuélienne manies
ses souvenirs d'enfance pour proposer
une cuisine d'inspiration sud américaine
une découverte de la rédaction de monaco
info sur place regarder une invitation
au voyage culinaire voilà ce que nous
propose victoria vallini là à seulement
27 ans la vénézuélienne est devenue la
première femme chef du coa mais aussi
d'un établissement de la société des
bains de mer
elle a d'ailleurs acquis l'art de
cuisiner ici à monaco aux côtés de chefs
tels que joël garault benoît vite avant
d'embarquer dans l'aventuré coyah j'ai
beaucoup aimé faire de la cuisine
française parce que je pense que ça
reste quand même les bases pour
apprendre à cuisiner et si on connaît
pas les bases on peut pas jouer avec la
cuisine comme comme il le faut je
reproduis mais plat d'enfance et je me
dis que si c'est ce que je cuisine peut
donner
donner des sensations
assez intense à moi je pense que si je
peux transmettre ça à un client chef de
parti il ya quatre ans à l'ouverture de
l'établissement monégasque victoria a
gravi petit à petit les échelons
elle mène sa brigade avec une main de
fer dans un gant de velours le tout dans
un esprit très familial
on l'a vu progresser on l'a vu grandir
au sein de la brigade est aujourd'hui
mais ça sa patte son empreinte et on est
tous très satisfaits du travail
la collaboration et hop elle est
toujours dans le détail dans la
recherche et ça j'aime beaucoup poussé
par son envie de retour aux sources la
chef vénézuélienne revisite les plats de
son enfance pour les adapter à la haute
gastronomie
le résultat est saisissant chaque
contrée chaque plat propose une saveur
unique tous aussi gourmands les uns que
les autres
le dépaysement est total je suis
vraiment sur des saveurs de de
l'amérique du sud sur quelque chose de
très gourmand sur quelque chose de
de simples je n'aime pas la cuisine
compliqué en soi et je n'aime plus je
pense que les gens ont envie ont besoin
de se détendre quand ils viennent à
table l'incontournable guacamole un
croustillant pop corn de poulets
empanadas tataki de boeuf à cause de
cheetah qui font par exemple partie des
mets proposés à la carte une expérience
unique qui nous offre un aller simple
pour l'amérique du sud tout en restant à
monaco voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette
édition du grand jt des territoires on
se retrouve très prochainement sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales et sur tv5
monde bon courage à tous au revoir
[Musique]